but as a purely historical matter  science has been wrong about pretty much  everything at some point for all of  history I'm not just talking about the  past couple of years I'm not just  talking about the World Health  Organization and the CDC and the NIH and  our old pal Dr fauci all of whom made  mistakes and told outright lies about  kovid the masks the social distancing  the vaccines the lockdowns and most  everything else I'm not even talking  about relatively recent historical  scientific flubs say at 1949 when the  neurologist Antonio AGA Moniz won the  Nobel Prize for inventing the lobotomy a  little bit of a black mark on science  but I'm not even just talking about that  I mean to look much more broadly at the  category of science as a whole because  virtually every single scientific theory  about every single thing has been  disproved and upended or replaced at  some point